I love spicy food I don't know if you
know about the last St let's go for
it okay and we need to pause for a
second let's go this is really
spicy oh
my as you guys know this show is all
about spice and of course we have to do
an episode on the spicy fried chicken
sandwich craze spicy fried chicken
sandwiches are are everywhere especially
in fast food where you see all these
chains trying to one up each other with
spice and flavor it's like a spice arms
race chefs started to catch on and put
their own crazy Twist on a fried chicken
sandwich today I'm going a quest to
learn about what makes a spicy chicken
sandwich so cravable why are people so
obsessed with it I'm hitting up two
locations in New York City to have some
insanely spicy chicken sandwiches with
their own cultural twist first my
neighbor pecking house it's a a Chinese
meat Southern spicy fried chicken
sandwich by Chef Eric Wang then we're
off to Rowdy rooster visiting my friend
Chef chintan for a spicy Indian inspired
fried chicken sandwich then afterwards
headed to mbar with K-Pop Stars homie to
make the ultimate Fried Chicken Sandwich
we'll see what we come up with let's go
I'm excited for this spicy chicken
sandwich
because there's a reason why it went
viral during the pandemic right and I
try to order it actually but his weight
list was like 10,000 people something
crazy so even if I wanted it I couldn't
get it here we are pcking
[Music]
house hey neighbor hey how are you
what's up Chef how you doing how are you
so nice to meet you finally I know heard
so much about you I was just like oh
wait right
[Applause]
there you go from fine dining yes to
Fried Chicken K yeah uh unfortunately
I'm going to have to say it was an
accident we were uh trying to save my
family's old restaurant peing house and
I was testing out a bunch of recipes and
you know this was obviously one of the
better ones and then uh fate decided for
me everything in that restaurant was
broken except for the friers except for
the friers so you're like what can I
make with this is what we're doing I
think everybody likes Fried Chicken yeah
I would say most people like sandwiches
so you know like two and two together I
think it definitely started with fast
food right like started with fast food
and then people just like caught on we
can credit Popeyes with that one I'm
really excited to try it all right cool
thanks Chef yeah boness thigh here thigh
and a do you brine uh yes we buttermilk
brine with Dijon all the classic like
country seasonings onion powder garlic
powder um put a little bit of sugar MSG
in there too for Flavor Flavor Flavor
MSG yeah and then uh we have our
breading which is a little bit unusual
it's flour potato starch and corn starch
okay try that for like 2 3 minutes get
that hot and crispy again this is our
chili oil right okay so how many vient
dangerous looking potion yeah is it
violent and dangerous we make an herb
duck fat okay we Infuse a lot of bay
leaves garlic spices the heat is tangent
chilies which is a very popular medium
heat Chinese chili okay oh so you dunk
it okay I love that all
right and then uh we're going to make
this extra hot for you so let me get
some gloves all right extra Hot For Me
so this is our habanero Citron
peppercorn powder these are ti Birds
Chili Peppers we pickle these that's
going to be spicy so we're going to
toast up our milk bread here it actually
kind of adds a barrier so the bread
doesn't get as soggy Cy
mayonnaise going to put our Chien on
there couple pickles beautiful top it up
it's very simple but uh you know as
we've talked at length here getting all
the details correct is an exhaustive
important process as a thank you Chef so
much much can't wait to try it enjoy
look at
this first
[Music]
bite wow that's
so so yummy M it's just so delicious it
has so much flavor it's like a smokey
heat you taste and then it's a spicy
heat then you get the pickly heat
incredibly crunchy juicy chicken but
that bread is awesome it's spicy but
very enjoyable and I think it's because
of a lot of that acid from the Tha chili
the pickle Tha chili and also the the
creamy element from the Q Mayo super
smart marinating the chicken in some MSG
because that kind of makes your mouth
water and actually goes really really
nicely with the spice it's a perfect
pairing
m m woo that was spicy Chef you en
enjoying it how's the heat level so good
the heat is like for me good like it's
perfect yeah just right I'm glad you
enjoy it m going eat this all spars a
lot of ideas I mean I love that milk
bread idea I definitely have to have
milk bread um ready for SOI milk bread
is
it going to try
it wow it's really good right I love
everything about this sandwich
man I have chicken on my pants all right
Chef thank you so much it was freaking
delicious thanks for coming by all right
stop one down number two
[Music]
next all right stop two we're here at
Rowdy rooster to visit my friend Chef
chintan spicy fried chicken sandwich
Indian inspired really spicy Apparently
one of the spiciest fried chicken
sandwich is that bill has ever had 100%
100% well we're going to test that I
think I can do better than Bill let's go
I had two bites I'm going to have three
bites all right oh my God Jeff chintan
oh my God it's been so long how are you
fantastic fantastic how are you doing
I'm good I'm good fantastic I for some
spicy fried chicken today I'm so in the
mood tell me about the inspiration
behind Rowdy rooster we come from India
and we actually eat a lot of fried food
there are fried fish there's Fried
Chicken everything possible Fri
everything fried vegetable is Indian
Fran always spicy it's a very subjective
thing mhm what is spicy for me might not
be spicy for you the cuisine is such
that uses the spices mhm so we have to
start at that level so yes it isic
starting at spicy so when you go to Five
it's yes what we Tred to do is we try to
Encompass different regions of India and
have spice blend from there okay Chef
why don't you come uh Isa is the we have
two big bosses actually so Isa is here
Marco hey Marco what's up so I wanted to
get two spice levels just to have like
comparison I was thinking I definitely
have to try Rowdy I mean this is heat
eaters how's your day looking after this
how's my day looking uh I can't handle
my spice though I'm Korean Eric Andre
was here and did the number four he said
it was spicier than anything on how okay
oh I'm kind of scared now why don't we
do one thing let's do uh uh let's do one
sandwich with the level two and two a
sandwich with level five mhm awesome
awesome thank you guys thank you Chef
see see you guys thank you thank you you
so thank you I'm extremely nervous
because if it's anything like the bomb
it's I know that's going to
hurt and you fried the chicken I was
crying after I ate that I think you
might after this yeah reg butter and
some Masala bread Masala did you cry I
teared up a little yeah te up a little
and then uh so you're going to eat this
with me I if you want so basically this
is the crazy
Ro the mango lassi helped a lot so
definitely keep two of those on
standby we need some P onions this is
the Min and cilantro sauce and finally
the the sculling y are you getting
nervous well you see be fidgeting right
it's almost CL let's hope I survive
this so we're going to start with the
mild the Ruffian this is level two at
first glance I'm very happy smells
pretty
spicy M it's delicious it's spicy but
it's not like crazy on a scale of one to
10 it's still like a five it's it
definitely has heat it is so yummy oh my
God it's so
good at one more bite and the chicken is
super juicy that's a good start oh yeah
my mouth is like you know I feel heat
around my lips it tastes so good I kind
of want to finish eating that but we
have a lot of work to do this is what
we're here for this is the Rowdy this is
the level five of five you got this i
got this right I got this you got this
we're doing wa it all
right yeah it's that building insane
heat it just it it hurts right now yeah
this is spicy really
bad
no Bill said he he took two bites I'm
going to take three just so I can beat
[Music]
Bill really really spicy but like I
don't know it's like enjoyable like I
for some reason it's not like the bomb
the bomb is like gross first of all it
doesn't taste good and that one immed
medely kind of makes you like cry it's
it's a very different sensation and I
think it's because it's the balance in
the sandwich with the pickles with the
yogurt and the bun if you like spicy
food it's something that you would
actually like like to eat like I I think
that I would order this again like if
I'm in the mood I saw you
Bill sh
love
you think you got it and then it moves
around it's
hot
yeah yeah two spicy chicken sandwiches
down now I'm going to go kind of take
some inspiration from the stuff that
I've tried and make my own spicy fried
chicken sandwich for
soie
[Music]
hi Muk bar you ready to eat some spicy
food I
am
hi hi nice to meet you nice to meet
you nice to meet you nice to meet you
thank you so much for being here no my
pleasure are you chicken yeah oh you
ready to get your hander I am okay so
I'm going to give you an apron yes I
love spicy food and I really need some
spice in my system because it's New York
I've been eating bagels and pastrami
sandwiches which is good a bit too much
so I need spice what is your feelings
about a spicy fried chicken sandwich how
can it not be good right how can it not
be good it's fried chicken so it could
be a little greasy but the spice is
there to like the oil and it's just
amazing for a really really good fried
chicken it has to be juicy and crispy
right right yeah so the key to uh the
juiciest chicken is brining and when you
brine something it kind of breaks down
the meat it's like marinating it then
it'll make a super succulent juicy
chicken O Okay juicy chicken sounds sexy
juicy chicken juicy chicken this is a
dry batter and this is what's going to
make it super crunchy I'm curious what
your spice tolerance is because mine is
pretty high really do you think it can
beat me
no I like it but but you know you're a
Korean we eat kimchi when we're like two
yeah exactly when you drop in the fryer
you always want to oh so we fry it for
about 5 minutes let it rest for a little
bit and then fry it again yeah double
fry always this is a really spicy chili
oil kug yes kug but I added some butter
to it too so you know you know for a
flavor you just basically like like this
but it'll still stay because it's an oil
yeah it looks
good
okay okay so this one is for you and
this one's for me so we're going to both
build a sandwich okay I'm going to build
my version you're going to BU build your
version okay I'm excited I did a little
digging I curated this station just for
you hopefully you'll you'll find some
things that you're familiar with and
that you really like and a really good
chicken sandwich for me is bread bread
is really important right bread is key
to a bread girl I like that bread girl
fangi fangi yes okay so I have three
different types of bread for you this
one is that classic potato roll and then
this one is a Brio and of course I have
milk bread because Milad good as a
Korean we love milk bread we do I'm
going to go with the bio extra butter
that's for you so since you're doing
that I'm going to go with milk I'm going
to go milk bread too okay o we have our
condiment bar okay and our dusting
station mhm dusting station cute name
this is flaming hot this is extra
flaming hot and this is that's the
Korean flaming hot I'm going to go with
ex XX okay go ahead yeah use your hands
dust it however you want I like to stick
my French fries in my hamburger oh
you're one of those yeah salty yeah
little flaming B yeah since homie is
going with the X Hot I think I'm going
to go with like the least hot you know I
I think I'm going to try to do like an
opposite thing of what you're doing so
we can have contrast right okay okay and
then now the fun part it's a condiment
bar yes so we have lettuce we have
tomato this is a KLA with like a Bui
flavored Mayo on it yeah so it's like a
Bui flavored KLA and then this one is a
pickled red chili uh Red Onion uhhuh
this is bread and butter pickles which
is more sweet and sour and then these
are pickled Thai Chili which is quite
spicy all right go for it Lettuce
lettuce baking it to be
healthy
COA pickled onion I'm going to go with
the Thai Chili yes Thai Chili careful
with those I'm going to do some lettuce
too cuz I feel like lettuce creates a
barrier between the chicken and then the
wet stuff so it doesn't get wet you
didn't put a tomato on yours mhm bread
and butter pickles okay this is where it
gets fun because we have our sauces this
is a Kim kimchi animal sauce kind of
like our Bing Mac sauce but with kimchi
in it so if you want to taste it that's
creamy that's good this one is a koochi
jang based sauce and I know you love
koochi Jang I do so it's not too
aggressive this is a toi sauce yeah it's
like a toi sauce exactly yes yes so you
love this oh it's so good this one's a
special sauce that I made just for you
yeah let me see if you know fuct it's
furu sauce I love furu sauce it's Prett
what do you think it's spicy it's so
good it's so good and spicy uh-huh p
means fire and top means chicken so
purak flam in chicken which is perfect
for this sandwich no it is actually it's
good for chicken so and then um I don't
know if you know about the last dab the
last the the spiciest of them all and
you know you don't have to do it but if
you would like to try
some this is a very iconic movement I
feel curiosity level is pretty high so I
think I do have to try I think you do
right yeah let's go for it I'll do one
with you it's a it's a little chunky
yeah okay here's
cheers oh I think I took too
much
oh it's not even like it's
like why do you eat
this I forgot how spicy it was oh
actually I need something
sweet yo s why did you do that I can't
even taste the chicken sandwich anymore
okay and we need to pause for a
secondo okay let's continue to show we
are back
back I am going to go with the bru and
the animal sauce okay awesome animal
sauce
yes nice little Buu oh yeah you're going
to do all three yeah go for it why not
why not all right so I'm going to do a
little bit of the chili sauce I'll do a
little p so I'll do the two so now we're
just going to put the top on mhm right
so oh nice
so one thing that I love about your
video is when you do B bom you take like
the biggest bites like you are not shy I
do yeah that's my favorite so I want to
see a big old bite in it let's see this
this a beautiful
sandwich oh
[Music]
yeah she has the hot sauce
stash M it's so good you need a
trademark that it's like a literally
like a it's so good it's actually really
really good I love the sauce okay the
the Cheetos gave me an extra crunch but
the chicken itself dipped in the chili
oil is just a different level of umami
there right there it's just good it's
really good and I love the pruda
carbonada sauce it really gives that
heavy creaminess into this light and
crunchy flavored chicken sandwich what
do you think about the spice level
enjoyable very and then the fullo is
just very fresh it's nice really nice
sounds really good I'm going to cut my
sandwich in half and have you try some
of this
too M M M MH mhm M different mhm but
yours is very fresh I think it's because
of the pickle and the Tomato all the
cold ingredients yeah with the Kang it
really goes well together it's really
nice more flavorful yeah you think so
yeah mine's like o and yours just
like mine just like okay we're GNA make
this a combo meal okay what is that this
is basically poutine and I know you're
Canadian so I had to make you my style
poutine fries with like melted cheese
and gravy then I added some spice to it
and I added some do to it so there's
like fried pieces of dock in the
fries yeah and then the sauce is kind of
like a spicy gravy and then some kimchi
on top oh my God I'm going to go with
dock a little bit kimchi
mhm and a bit of Kang sauce I love that
she knows how to
eat mhm mhm mhmh mhm it's really good oh
do good the kimchi is
amazing so so me you have anything going
on anything special I just released my
album game plan
game plan game plan uh the title song is
fast forward and we also have a music
video for a song called gold gold gold
yes I've seen it yes I have two music
videos out and have a full album and
fast forward is the song you need to
listen to so please go check that out
check it out
guys amazing I am Korean amazing
yeah oh no my coffee
Cofe yeah I'm
[Music]
sorry it's really bad I forgot I for I
haven't done it in a while I forgot how
bad it was you guys oh my God I totally
forgot that's horrific I'm
sorry I forgot how bad I was like no
it's not that
[Music]
bad no way I'm putting that in my
sandwich I am
not
[Music]
hey guys it's Esther from heat eaters
thanks for watching please like And
subscribe and for more episodes click
here